Je suis juste que cela fait si
longtemps et je suis ravi que les fans le
voient, j'ai l'impression qu'ils attendent
depuis longtemps, nous travaillons dessus
depuis si longtemps que c'est enfin agréable de
juste  que ce soit nous lisons tous des livres et nous
avons tous une idée de ce à quoi ils
vont ressembler et nous les jouons dans notre
tête et nous les diffusons et
tout, donc c'est juste excitant de
pouvoir faire partie de  la chose mais vous
savez que nous avons créé notre meilleure version de
ce qu'ils veulent vous savez et c'est juste
une chose vraiment cool et je suis juste
tellement excité qu'ils le voient je
dirais merci parce que vous savez que c'est
tellement important  une partie de cela et je suis
si heureux que vous sachiez que ce ne sont pas seulement
des grandes premières, mais des stars de cinéma,
les premières sont pour les fans, je veux dire,
et ils peuvent le voir avant tout le monde et
je pense que c'est une très bonne façon d'
honorer et de dire  merci hé
génial c'est génial tu sais garder le contact avec les
gens de cette façon c'est juste c'est ouais c'est
assez spec  ial et je suis très très chanceux je
n'ai pas de mots c'était juste incroyable le jeu d'
acteur la chimie c'est vraiment ils ont
vraiment donné vie au livre ils
étaient parfaits ensemble j'y ai
pensé pendant des mois et des mois et des
mois et puis maintenant ça
Je pense que la façon dont ils décrivent la
relation entre les deux
était tout simplement parfaite, je pense que cela
vous rapproche en quelque sorte de vous connaissez deux
autres significatifs, alors elle m'a entraîné
dedans et j'ai vraiment aimé ça alors j'ai suggéré
pour  sûr que
tu es